نمو مقياس الأمازون من أمازون ،
شهد عملاق التكنولوجيا أرباحًا أكثر من
ثلاثة أضعاف في الربع الأول إلى أكثر من
ثمانية مليارات دولار
حيث أنفق المستهلكون على الإنترنت واعتمد المزيد من
الشركات على خدماتها السحابية
cle sebastian كانت تتدفق
على الأرقام كلير قرأت في الواقع
أن
الأرباح التي  لقد حققوا في 12 شهرًا
المنتهية في 31 مارس أكثر من
الأرباح التي حققوها في السنوات الثلاث بأكملها
حتى عام 2019 ، أعني أنه لا يمكننا حتى التعرف على
حجم الأرباح خلال فترة الوباء الماضية ،
نعم جوليا  أعتقد أنه من الواضح جدًا
أن الوباء كان جيدًا للغاية بالنسبة إلى
أمازون على الرغم من
أنه كان مكلفًا للغاية ، فقد قالوا
إنهم أنفقوا حوالي 2 مليار دولار على 19
تكاليف سرية ذات صلة في هذا الربع
وما زالوا
ينفقون مليار ونصف مليار في
الربع القادم ولكن على الرغم من
أن ربحية هذه الشركة
غير عادية وأريد أن أشير
إلى رقم واحد لأن aws هو
خدمات أمازون ويب
لا يزال rvice
محركًا رئيسيًا للربحية ،
فقد كان حوالي 12 ونصف بالمائة من
المبيعات ولكن 47
من الدخل التشغيلي ، لذا انظروا أنهم قد
حصلوا بالفعل على وفورات الحجم في
أعمال التجارة الإلكترونية الخاصة بهم
والتي تسمح لهم بتحقيق الأرباح هناك
إضافة إلى ذلك  الربحية الهائلة
والتكلفة المنخفضة نسبيًا
لـ AWS وستلاحظ كيف
ينمو محرك أمازون هذا